[Musique]
l'enregistrement de l'album la ville et
vittoz avait été filmé en janvier 1969
en mode cinéma vérité en 1970 un
documentaire de 80 minutes avait vu le
jour mais cinquante ans plus tard le
réalisateur peter jackson a sorti des
voûtes les 57 eur d'image pour en faire
un film de six heures qui sortira à
partir du 25 novembre
[Rires]
[Musique]
la nouvelle bande annonce est à couper
le souffle car voici les beatles comme
vous ne les avez jamais entendu ou vu un
gros plan on assiste à leur processus de
création comme si on était en studio
avec eux et oui il se dispute on entend
par mes carnets s'exclamer que dans 50
ans on dira que le groupe s'est séparé
parce que yoko ono s'est assis sur un
amplificateur
je pense la beauté du film de peter
jackson du nouveau documentaire cosplay
gamme black ce qui va nous montrer
justement tout le côté qu'on n'avait
jamais vu c'est à dire le côté harmonie
le côté et méfiante les gars et cela le
côté synergie de ces camions studio
en attendant le film c'est la fête pour
les fans des beatles puisque demain
vendredi sortir à la reddition de la
libye dans la version super deluxe on
retrouvera bien sûr l'album original
remixé par john martin mais aussi en
album de 27 prises inédites et puis le
fameux mix de green john qui n'était pas
sorti à l'époque les 200 m
pour doublement génial c'est qu'on
aimerait mix que les vitraux souhaité
pour les t2 bis qui décline jones qui
profite aux prospecteurs c'est l'album
que mais qui déteste encore aujourd'hui
est d'avoir le vrai album d'époque qui
aurait voulu danser on ne jamais eu sa
première fois qu'on voit d'abord donc
sage pour simplement intéressés
[Musique]
avec le splendide heureux mixage de
l'album la libye avec la sortie d'un
nouveau livre et avec ce film qui sera
disponible sur dix n'est plus limitée
aux montre une fois de plus qu'ils sont
toujours dans le vent ici louis fait
déprimer radio canada
[Musique]